As much as we'd like to focus
on creating and managing
threads and work
packets, we tend
to ignore the biggest, hardest
problem in threading, memory.
My name is Colt McAnlis.
And while threading
and memory have
a long, complicated
history in programming,
there are some specific
nuances on Android
that you need to be aware of.
You gotta remember that
memory in computing
isn't really thread safe.
When two threads are operating
on the same block of memory,
weird things happen.
I mean, you can get memory
contention problems with read
write access order,
ABA problems,
rips in the fabric
of space time.
OK, maybe not-- maybe
not the last one.
But anyhow, fixing these means
restricting memory access
from threads using locking,
which is a whole separate video
series that we're not going
to get into right now.
But most important to
understand is that Android
isn't immune to these problems.
For the most part,
the same techniques
you use to deal with these
issues on other platforms
can be applied here, too.
But there are a
few specific cases
that you need to be aware of.
Let's start with the fact that
by design, UI objects are not
thread safe.
UI objects are expected
to be created, used,
and destroyed all
on the UI thread,
and not guaranteed to behave
properly on any other threads.
Trying to modify or even
reference them on other threads
can throw exceptions, cause
silent failures, crashes,
and just general weirdness.
In fact, just holding a direct
reference to a UI object
on a worker thread
can be a problem.
For example, your work object
may contain a reference
to a view.
But before your work completes
on the worker thread,
the view is removed
from the view
hierarchy on the main thread.
So what do you do here?
I mean, you can't trust any
of the properties of that view
since the data has changed.
And updating those
properties doesn't really
mean anything, since it's not
part of the hierarchy anymore
and won't be drawn
to the screen.
And this gets
crazy really quick.
Now remember, views
contain references
to their owning activity.
I mean, we did a whole video
on how leaking those views
can cause all sorts
of memory problems.
But this gets even worse
when threading is involved.
If an activity is
destroyed but there still
exists a threaded block of
work that references it,
the activity won't get collected
until that work finishes.
So if you kick off some work
and the user rotates the screen
three times in a row
before that work completes,
you could end up with three
instances of that activity
object resident in memory.
And to be clear, it's not
just explicit references
to UI objects that you
need to worry about.
You also have to be cautious of
implicit references, as well.
Check out this very common
seen-all-the-time coding
pattern in Android apps.
You've got some
threading object that's
declared as an inner
class of an activity.
The problem here is that
the async task object
now has an implicit reference
to the enclosing activity
and will keep that
reference until the work
object has been destroyed.
The result is the same problem.
Until this work
completes, the activity
stays around in memory.
And by the way,
this type of pattern
also leads to common types of
crashes seen in Android apps.
Some block of threading
work has kicked off.
But the user hits Back or
does something else to change
the top-most activity.
Later, when the
threaded work completes,
it tries to make updates to a
state that's no longer valid.
The result is a dialog
box notifying me
that an app I haven't used
for 10 minutes has crashed,
which is kind of
awkward for everybody.
The takeaway here is that
you shouldn't hold references
to any types of UI
specific objects
in any of your threading
scenarios, which
leads to the natural
question, how
are we supposed to update
the UI from threaded work.
The trick here is to force
the top level activity
or fragments to be the sole
system responsible for updating
the UI objects.
For example, when you'd
like to kick off some work,
create a work record that
pairs a view with some update
function.
When that block of
work is finished,
it submits the results back to
the activity using an intent
or a run on UI thread call.
The activity can then
call the update function
with the new information,
or if the view isn't there,
just drop the work altogether.
And if the activity that
issued the work was destroyed,
then the new activity won't
have a reference to any of this
and will just drop the work too.
See?
No crashes, no memory
leaks, just pure clean fun.
Now, if you ever
want a deeper look
at how threading and memory
are working together,
make sure to check out
the powerful new tools
inside of Android Studio, which
just got an awesome revamp
as a version 2.0.
The deeper you go into
Android performance,
the more you realize
how important
memory is on this
platform, which
is why you should check out
the rest of the memory videos
on the Android Performance
Patterns playlists.
And don't forget to check out
our Google+ community as well.
So keep calm, profile your
code, and always remember,
perf matters.
[MUSIC PLAYING]